Olá o que acontece se você tomar suco de
sals todos os dias por 30 dias a
natureza nós sabemos que é incrível não
é mesmo ela é tão sábia e nos presenteia
com uma infinidade de alimentos cheios
de nutrientes que podem fazer uma
diferença incrível na nossa saúde e o
vegetal sals é um verdadeiro aliado
especialmente pra saúde do nosso sistema
linfático também do fígado da nossa
digestão e até da tireoide muita gente
usa o sals naa sopa em saladas mas eu
vou compartilhar com vocês uma maneira
diferente e para ser sincero uma das
minhas favoritas consumir o sals em
forma de suco e olha que não é qualquer
suco não ele tem um jeito certo de se
fazer para que você possa aproveitar o
máximo todos os benefícios você vai
tomar esse suco pela manhã em jejum como
verdadeira lixi para começar o dia com
pé direito bem o sals também conhecido
como i
tem como nome científico apium
graveolens e é uma hortaliça bastante
nutritiva e bem fácil de encontrar aqui
no Brasil mas antes de mais nada vamos
falar um pouco sobre porque o sals é tão
especial primeiro o sals é uma excelente
fonte de vitamina K que é essencial para
congola sanguínea adequada ou seja ajuda
a evitar problemas como sangramentos
excessivos um dos nutrientes mais
interessantes do sal é o libidio esse
mineral embora necessário em
pequeníssimas quantidades é um iGo
elemento ele desempenha um papel muito
importante Vital especialmente no detox
de metais pesados no nosso organismo e o
que é preocupante é que muitas pessoas
estão deficientes em molibidênio e não
fazem a menor ideia não não sabem nada
disso E claro o salsão também é rico em
outros nutrientes como vitamina A
vitamina C folato que é a vitamina B9
magnésio potássio também é uma fonte
poderosa de antioxidantes agora eu quero
destacar um composto específico do sal
que merece toda a nossa atenção nós
estamos falando da
apigenina ela é amplamente estudada por
suas propriedades antiinflamatórias
antioxidantes anticancerígenas e
neuroprotetoras então esse composto Não
só está presente no sals mas também
outros alimentos como é o caso da salsa
milho e a camomila o que que torna então
a apigenina um elemento tão especial ela
pode ajudar a reduzir inflamação no
corpo o que é benéfico para diversas
condições crônicas como doenças
cardíacas artrite a apigenina possui
propriedades antivirais promissoras tá
sendo estudado para isso então em
estudos tem sido demonstrado a sua
capacidade de inibir a replicação de
vírus como é o caso do herp simples da
Hepatite C da gripe e tem bar Então ela
atua modulando a resposta imunológica
aumentando a produção de interferons e
pode bloquear entrada viral nas células
hospedeiras então estudos mostram que
ela fortalece os neurônios do cérebro
age diretamente na sinapse das
Comunicações das conexões entre os
neurônios então desta forma temos
neurônios mais fortes o que se traduz em
uma melhora significativa em várias
funções cerebrais como é o caso da
cognição a memória o funcionamento Geral
do cérebro então a apigenina lembra
desse nome
apigenina também tem sido estudada por
seus potenciais benefícios no combate ao
câncer especialmente o câncer de mama E
adivinha só o sals tem doses bem
interessantes desse composto nos seus
talos o que faz dele um verdadeiro
aliado pra saúde geral agora vamos falar
sobre Porque é tão interessante consumir
o suco de sals em jejum pela manhã
primeiramente o suco de sals é um
verdadeiro aliado na desintoxicação do
sistema linfático que por sua vez é
fundamental pra eliminação de várias
toxinas vários resíduos que se acumulam
no nosso corpo quando o fígado está
sobrecarregado de toxinas isso afeta
diretamente o sistema linfático levando
ao acúmulo de resíduos no organismo
então resíduos que são ruins para nós o
suco de sals entra em Ação ele vai dar
aquele empurrãozinho essencial paraa
limpeza dessas toxinas tanto no fígado
quanto no sistema linfático então em
outras palavras ele é como escudo
protetor do fígado Além disso ao
fortalecer esse Nobre órgão fígado o
suco de sals pode ajudar na Regeneração
das células hepáticas e assim prevenir a
sobrecarga desse órgão Vital melhorando
a suas funções Gerais e tem mais ele
também promove a produção de bile que é
fabricado no fígado e é fundamental
paraa digestão das gorduras quando
falamos de digestão o suco de sals é um
verdadeiro amigo do nosso sistema
digestório ele é muito eficaz em
aumentar a produção de ácido clorídrico
no estômago algo que hoje em dia Muitas
pessoas têm em níveis baixos e a falta
desse ácido pode causar uma série de
problemas como o refluxo indigestão e
desconforto após as afeições o suco de
sals ajuda a prevenir tudo isso além de
limpar o intestino evitando sintomas
como inchaço e constipação também
auxilia na proteção da mucose intestinal
graças à sua potente ação
antiinflamatória ele pode proteger o
intestino da inflamação mas não para por
aí se você incluir o suco de sals na sua
rotina ele pode até beneficiar sua
tireoide isso porque o sals contém
antioxidantes e minerais são
fundamentais para função da tireoide que
ajudam a regular a produção de hormônios
Além disso ele Combate o stresse
oxidativo que pode prejudicar a tireoide
especialmente em caso de tiroidite
Hashimoto Então esse ataque autoimune
que as pessoas sofrem as portadoras da
tiroidite de Hashimoto ele pode ser
amenizado pelos antioxidantes que estão
presentes no sal isso vai ajudar a
proteger a glândula Nobre tireoide se
você também incluir outros alimentos que
protegem a tireoide na sua dieta como as
castanhas que são ricas em selênio os
benefícios podem ser ainda maiores então
alguns especialistas defendem que o
salsão possui uma propriedade especial
única de combater o vírus epsen bar o
mesmo que causa a doença mononucleose
infecciosa conhecida entre aspas Como a
doença do beijo em algumas pessoas que
tiveram essa infecção o vírus pode
permanecer no organismo de forma latente
E com o tempo vai ter uma predileção
pelos tecidos da tireo podendo atacar o
tecido tiroidiano e prejudicar esse
órgão então durante esse estado latente
o vírus não causa sintomas de forma
direta Mas pode reativar se em certas
condições como é o caso do estresse da
imunossupressão outras doenças e atacar
tireode outros tecidos do corpo assim o
sals Poderia ajudar a combater esse
vírus latente no nosso corpo
especialmente se consumido regularmente
na verdade alguns autores afirmam que o
salsão tem a capacidade limpar a
tireoide das toxinas do vírus epsen bar
Além disso ele poderia ajudar a
estimular a produção do hormônio T3 que
é o hormônio ativo e produzido pela
glândula tireoide e como preparar então
o suco de sal é muito simples Você vai
precisar de um maço de sal que deve ter
uma média de 8 talos primeiro Lave bem
os talos de sal em Água corrente para
remover qualquer sujeira o resíduo e
depois que você fez essa limpeza para
facilitar na hora de fazer o suco corte
o sal em pedaços menores isso vai ajudar
bastante especialmente se você for
utilizar um liquidificador agora passe o
sals pela centrífuga ou se você estiver
usando o liquidificador Talvez você
precise adicionar um pouquinho de água
para ajudar a bater até que o sals fique
completamente
triturado bem pessoal tem que triturar
ou bater bem em seguida é hora de coar
use um coador fino ou até mesmo um pano
de algodão para remover a polpa se você
prefere um suco mais fino essa receita
rende cerca de 300 a 400 ml de suco um
copão perfeito para começar o dia e aqui
vai o segredo beba na hora assim que
você terminar de coar Esse é o truque
para garantir que você aproveite todos
os nutrientes fresquinhos do sals e o
melhor o sals É extremamente baixo em
calorias não causa aumento do açúcar no
sangue muito pelo contrário pode até
ajudar a estabilizar os níveis de Açúcar
isso faz do sals uma excelente opção
para começar o seu dia com leveza com
saúde com disposição o ideal é beber o
suco em jejum e esperar pelo menos 15
minutos antes de tomar o seu café da
manhã habitual se você tomar o suco
junto com o café da manhã ou com o
lanche da tarde a absorção dos elementos
nutrientes pode ser reduzida Tente fazer
isso por 30 dias e observe seus
benefícios agora o que mais você poderia
adicionar esse suco de sal bem o ideal é
beber o suco sem mais nada sem adicionar
mais nenhum outro elemento e quanto
adicionar frutas é é possível você
adicionar frutas mas é importante ser
cuidadoso se você planeja consumir esse
suco de forma diária Eu recomendo
escolher frutas com baixo índice
glicêmico como é o caso das frutas
vermelhas ou coco essas opções são mais
interessantes para manter a carga
glicêmica sempre baixa mas isso não
significa que você não possa usar outras
frutas de forma ocasional de vez em
quando por exemplo adicionar uma maçã ao
suco de sals combina muito bem e dá um
toque refrescante além de fornecer
outras vitaminas pessoalmente eu prefiro
comer a maçã como fruta e tomar o suco
de sals Puro porque que eu acho é mais
saudável e benéfico mas incluir uma maçã
no suco de sal uma ou duas vezes vezes
por semana pode ser uma ideia assim
interessante uma ou duas vezes por
semana outra adição que você pode
considerar é o uso do Limão Associação
com limão que vai deixar o seu suco de
sals ainda mais refrescante e saboroso
agora uma coisa muito importante que eu
quero destacar nenhum alimento por si só
faz milagre se alguém te disser que um
único suco vai resolver todos os seus
problema na vida pagar suas contas e
boleto desconfie Claro existe situações
de que uma deficiência de nutriente pode
estar causando algum problema específico
E aí claro que consumir um alimento rico
nesse nutriente vai te ajudar sim OK mas
na maioria das vezes o que precisamos é
de um conjunto de medidas de ações para
realmente melhorar a nossa
saúde Especialmente quando falamos de
doenças crônicas degenerativas então o
que que isso significa estilo de vida
saudável que nós batemos nessa martelo
todos os dias aqui o estilo de vida
saudável é a chave isso começa com
alimentação equilibrada porque o nosso
corpo precisa de uma variedade de
nutrientes nutrientes diversos cores
diferentes para funcionar bem então
muitas vezes um único alimento pode ser
rico em um certo nutriente mas ele não
vai conseguir suprir todas as suas
necessidades as necessidades do seu do
nosso organismo então por isso é tão
importante diversificar o que colocamos
no nosso prato então meu meus queridos
Muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço um beijo no seu coração
Você é fera